good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having an amazing day just
amazing I'm having an amazing day why
are you having an amazing day turdy Lou
why am I having an amazing day oh I
don't know because it's a Jackson Claude
in recipe in recipe in studio original
recipe kind of day that is a great day
yeah that's my reason that's your reason
it's the only reason you need and it's
reason enough it's reason enough for me
hey guys happy to be back in studio with
my girly swirly twirly but it is getting
harder and harder to get ready in the
morning it's not even like what you
think like the getting dressed like I
know I have four clothes yeah I have the
items and I just pair them you know mix
and match but it's just like the doing
my hair yeah the standing for that you
look beautiful thank you and we're so
glad that you you put you at it together
yeah it's just it's crazy because
we stopped podcasting when I was
pregnant with Harry we stopped coming
into the studio because like um was
popping off yeah so we did remote
podcasting for like the last two months
of my pregnancy so I don't know if I've
ever been in this video this pregnant
well it's so great to have you both here
it's just it's hard to get around and
like it's hard to sit because I can't
cross my legs really it's not good for
my circulation oh so I'm I'm like man
spreading a little bit Yeah but also I
saw a reels Tick Tock that said like
you're actually even though you assume
pregnant women sit like this which is
like leg spread back like lean back it's
not good for your circulation either
you're supposed to sit like
I don't know I feel like the cave women
were fine you know
I don't know but they didn't have these
reclining Google chairs yeah I will say
these bugle chairs are not like
pregnancy friendly and
everybody just don't it's not like
Pleasant to look at you look great I'm
just trying to figure figure it out but
drop a comment
sound off in the comments I feel like
Joey Canasta but these chairs are hard
to sit in and I believe like we got rid
of our old pink couches because those
were actually hard to sit in yes and
then we have these two chairs we thought
we were like entering a new era and
we're not maybe it's just like chairs
maybe it's us no maybe it's chairs and
not us because look we've tried that's a
terrible chair yeah but that's a
terrible chair I just think it's hard
the Thrones were bad actually the Thorns
were not bad I just think it's hard to
be
to exist yeah it's so Socrates you want
to hear something funny sure so choice
no Ben went to dinner last night and
when he was gone for like four hours he
went to dinner at the Mark like the
fancy hotel Uptown where like everyone
stays for the Met Ball and he came home
and he was like
the weirdest thing happened
as he was leaving dinner there was like
a protest outside the mark and Ben was
like chanting it the whole night they
were saying the most random things the
Mark has mice the mark denies the
Holocaust the mark supports Epstein and
Ben was like how are these three things
related first of all second I went on
Twitter to try to see what like the
drama with the mark there was nothing
Ben said it was like six people standing
outside with signs it wasn't like an
organized protest but the Mark has mice
the mark denies the Holocaust the mark
supports Epstein
now I tried to look into the veracity it
feels like a riddle of literally I tried
to look into the veracity of these
claims and I came up with nothing
and it's like if the Mark has mice like
don't you think that they feel bad about
that too like you're gonna prove it also
in this city we're gonna hurt us mice no
in this city who doesn't have mice right
but like mice are like kind of the sweet
ones in this city it could be a rat or a
roach rats Run This Town
super roach
yeah Super Rat I think I was the rats
that were eating other rats rat on rat
crying right it was called the Super Rat
but I do think the roads have become
super as well the roaches yeah they've
always been super so true so Ben's
literally in the shower the Mark has
mice literally walking around the house
making his coffee the Mark has my it's
so funny and I honestly like I don't
know what's going on at the Mark and so
it's the mark supports Epstein I think
like one time Jeffrey Epstein state of
the March that's where like all rich
people stay I don't think it's you know
a conspiracy that they were in on it
whoever brush shoulders are sheltered or
hung out Jeffrey Epstein like was
accused at one point yeah if we're
protesting them out like you're all done
right so we're done I don't know what's
going on but all I know is the Mark has
mice
and now I'm over here and then read it
to my tonight's the Holocaust which is a
real accusation when the hotel that I'm
staying at denies the Holocaust then I
just I cannot be there when you can't
even check in without the concierge
being like the Holocaust never happened
it's so annoying I hate when that
happens it happens all the time very
frequently so I could I totally believe
that me too and I also believe the Mark
has mice
I guess we'll have to wait and say maybe
I gotta go to the mark
it out by the way these things are all a
legend and the Mark is a Lovely Hotel
and bears are the food was
that I would love to stay at yeah I've
never stayed there I've eaten there same
we had my college graduation dinner
there and none of those things that
they're chanting like would stop me from
wanting to stay there no me neither
honestly no it's still fabulous 100 mice
and all no like seriously mice is like
okay cool no like in the grand scheme of
like the Vermin we get here in New York
mice I think are the cleanest option
even though I don't know I think I would
prefer a bug
I know roaches are disgusting but
they're so small like mice are like
animals I know that's why you gotta get
a cat
that's I'd rather have the mice the mark
[__] unleash I heard of cats no that's
what they did in Israel yeah I know if
you ever have been to Israel like you're
eating at a restaurant they have like
thousands of cats roaming the streets
and it's because like at the same time
but like if you're just out and about
like you'll see stray cats and it's
because like many many years ago they
had a mice problem so they released
cats just to live and now they have a
cat problem and that's the plot of the
movie Cat spoiler alert is it no it
should be by the way I've never seen the
movie Cats I have Nary a clue what the
film is about if I had to guess the plot
I think I would say
it's a ragtag group of cats
Who start a theater group
I just have in my head from Kimmy
Schmidt that's just cats introducing
themselves yeah well that that whole
thing in Kimmy Schmidt was historical so
it's obviously like
a mystery what the plot of cats is right
it's not like a known thing clearly and
it's not memorable yeah and it's not
about the plot I think it's about the
cats right meow rare kitty I bet she's
Crossing her legs don't tell the doctor
Dad I'm calling him up so that's what I
did last night just kind of look into
the mark God and their Litany of
accusations and oh I I caught up on and
just like that I know you didn't watch
the second episode but it was worse than
the first it was but until you stop but
I can't that's a thing and I think a lot
of people because I posted it on my
story agree like it's actually harmful
to keep watching it's a form of
self-harm yeah but you literally can't
stop like if I were on a monitor while I
was watching like my levels would be
like spiking like heart rate like just
whatever else they monitor like it was
giving me a physical visceral reaction I
know but there are a few like really
um endearing characters like Anthony of
course Anthony's the best and because
Samantha's gone he obviously got a
bigger role and it's the role he was
born to play like he's so funny ltw Lisa
Todd wexley I thoroughly enjoy I
actually would enjoy Elisa Todd wexley
spin-off she's a fabulous life but oh my
God and I hate to say like Charlotte
I'm sorry and actually I know Miranda's
like having this like Spiral moment in
Santa Monica but she was being really
funny in the second episode oh and one
of her favorite actors Oliver Hudson
Kate Hudson's brother is in it oh that's
a plus yeah I like him they've always
had plenty of good cabios I don't know
ltw because I only watched the first
episode and she was just like in her
closet in lingerie the whole time
working on her film Vlog yeah well so
she working on her blog I mean she keeps
losing her edits and I was like she lost
her edit again this episode
that's so funny she literally did like
right before they were going to the
netball
um
she is one of the moms at Charlotte
school and in the first season like
Charlotte was obsessed with her like
wanted to become her friend and actually
did end up becoming her friend and all
the ladies really like her
um so that's like who she is in the
context of the show okay and she was
probably the only one who looked even
remotely good at the Met Ball actually
Seema looked good too I only saw like
half the looks so far
Carrie wore her wedding dress
oh my God and that seamstress the
designer yeah that was weird like and
Carrie's just like allowing this girl to
just ruin her run a muck in her home
right that was six hours and she didn't
want to like run to bergdorf's no just
in case or even look at her clothes or
call a friend or contact Right In The
Biz oh so in the second episode I do
think you'll find it interesting that
Carrie's podcast got canceled no so she
goes well that frees up my week and now
she doesn't have a job oh wow I wonder
what she'll do next I know because she's
really always been so career oriented so
you know she's a widow now she like
doesn't I think she was career oriented
but she also like needed to work to live
right she sold that apartment big and
her lived in she obviously got
everything from his will and he had a
you know a million oh you didn't see
that the first season in his will he
obviously like left everything to carry
but he had like a million dollar trust
set up for Natasha and she spent like a
couple episodes trying to figure out why
and I think it was just like his way of
saying sorry but
so we had like a spare Millie right
right she's fine oh and she sold the
apartment and lives in her Studio I'm
not worried about her finances actually
for the first time in the history of the
show it's such a relief I'm just like
her her purpose her reason dad's hair
yeah yeah but I think a lot of her
purpose in the beginning her career
driven like her ambitiousness was driven
by you know the need to pay bills of
course but that's a need yeah but I'm
saying now yeah
what's her reason dead hair I don't know
something to think about and I feel like
henceforth the show doesn't have a
reason to tear yeah no it feels kind of
aimless
like Carrie like Carrie maybe it's a
reflection of what she's going through
or just the fact that they can't come up
with new show ideas yeah
so that's what I did hurt myself
why was her podcast canceled the whole
network went downhill
um so it wasn't because it wasn't a
personal attack I am I think it would
have been better
see her go down
the bell in Dior yeah yeah yeah exactly
that's like one of the best episodes
when she falls in Dr Harry falling in
Dior is
a reward for getting through all the
seasons of Sex in the City there's also
an episode where she falls on that um
catwalk she does like a modeling thing
for like real people and models yeah and
she completely Falls in and she's only
wearing a pair of underwear yeah that
was that that's bad that was good but it
doesn't hit it because
like during the petrovsky episodes where
she's insufferable yeah yeah so it's
just like
it's just more there you go they and
there she went yeah
oh so what else is what would you watch
what'd you do would you see what do you
know did I watch anything no I tried to
like have a moment like with the Martian
again I just like put on a movie
recreate the magic I don't even think I
turned on the TV but I didn't read I
think I was just kind of like [__]
around on my phone what's the best and
then I went to sleep early because I was
really tired but I did watch a little
bit of murder on the Orient Express I
like that movie yesterday we loved that
movie and it was like I only watched the
last 30 minutes it was like emotional oh
okay I think that's you I think it was
me too yeah it's like a pregnancy thing
it's not like I don't know it's not a
reality thing
but like it's a spoiler alert major
spoiler it's a Revenge killing and like
all of the people who participate in it
on the train um are connected are
connected and it was because like this
little baby girl was killed and then
like I guess her parents maybe committed
suicide like it just destroyed this
whole family and it was just like I
guess I guess it is like a deep tragedy
and the grandma is the one who
spearheaded the whole Revenge Revenge
and Michelle Pfeiffer just like
she spoke my heart she stole my heart
hmm yeah Penelope Cruz is also in the
movie and her acting was actually
atrocious wow
um and that was just something I wanted
to note something else I wanted to note
is that I could not sleep last night I
didn't go to bed till two was so
annoying Ben's passed out
um and I had to pee and I was like
literally so afraid that the thing would
happen again we're like Ben so did you
turn the lights I turned the light on it
was so loud I flushed I'm like um um
just in case he was getting up and had
to pee all good the light should have
suffice yeah it should have but like I
was just taking a bunch of precautions
great you learned something new every
day and I did in fact make it chili I
didn't Ben did
um I wrote a big old Tupperware for Jax
to the studio today she's going to bring
it home I think Harry's going to have it
and it is still a chilly day the weather
has held up the weather for like the
last week is like trash yeah it doesn't
know what it's doing what happened to
hot girl summer it feels like impending
rain at all time but there's like major
storms throughout the country so if all
we have is gray skies and a chilly Vibe
consider ourselves lucky I'm not gonna
so enjoy the chili I will say so Ben
wasn't Ben was once again being very
generous making the chili for me he was
headed out to his dinner I told you
about at the Mark where they have mice
and deny the Holocaust
and um so he made it for me and he was
like I'm letting it simmer like eat it
whenever it's on low so then I go and
I'm like mixing it making sure it's not
getting burnt and I realized he forgot
to put the beans in the beans have
become just like this kind of your guys
it's like Achilles yeah so I text Ben
I'm like oh [__] like the bit the beans
weren't put in what do I do and he
didn't answer so I just threw the beans
in I was on FaceTime with you yeah I
threw the beans in and I let it Chill on
the stove for like 20 minutes and then I
got hungry so I made myself a bowl
packed it all up in tupperware did the
dish so I could enjoy the rest of my
night and turns out the chili was great
except for the beans like the one thing
I had to do it just it wasn't right it
wasn't like when Ben made it thus
proving your point that I'm quite
literally incapable of making one thing
in the kitchen that's not toxic no it's
so crazy like the one it's just to pour
beans in mix it up and chill right yeah
couldn't even do that yeah because also
an error there was you're sweeping ways
because you should you could have had
like your bowl of chili with premature
beans they're already cooked it's fine
but it could have left the big vat that
I made for you which is chill and let
the rest of the chili be Perfection I
could maybe anyone can relate to this
like I couldn't really enjoy my night
and like enjoy the chili and like get
back in bed like I couldn't enjoy that
knowing I still had dishes to do like I
need to have a clean sweep of things
like a Clean Plate literally before I
could like fully dive into the night if
that makes sense no I understand but now
we are we all suffer we all Suffer Well
I think you can just dump the Tupperware
back onto the stove yeah that's what I'm
gonna do let it simmer your whole house
will smell like chili it's so nice right
and I'll get to like kind of hack the
chili Vibe and then it's like you made
it yourself yeah without all the
chopping without all the chopping
there's it's a really good we're in our
chicken chili era we're gonna kind of
over beef oh another crazy thing that
happened to me you guys reminded of this
too this is this is what I was doing
yesterday this story occupied my whole
day my whole day the great mystery of
2023.
so after yesterday's episode if you
listen to yesterday's episode you know I
wanted to make a chili Jackie inspired
me I was even saying on the episode she
should instacart the ingredients now and
I did because I had to work and I had
things to do I didn't have time to go to
the grocery store
so I instacart one order from Fairway
which is just like a regular grocery
store here I got like the beans all the
things except the meat the beans beans
the beans beans onions garlic Peppers
whatever we needed and then like stuff
from my house too like I need a coffee
bait and then I place a second order at
Park East kosher butcher which is a
favorite location of ours Upper East
Side our go-to butcher I only recently
found out there on instacart which I
love game changing so I got the ground
chicken but then I also got things for
my house Ben loves this brand of uh
kosher turkey called SV or whatever so
I'm placing the orders going about my
day and then the Shopper starts texting
me and he said oh they don't have the SV
turkey the one that Ben loves and I find
that so odd because like it's a staple
of the Park East kosher butcher I'm like
okay like what else do they have and he
sends me a picture of the turkey aisle
and the deli meats the deli meals
packaged to the uh to the untrained eye
it might not have seemed like anything
I'm like zooming in and I see
pork bacon Oscar Meyer bologna I see
like Applewood brand Oscar Meyer brand
all these very classic grocery store
brands that are not sold at a kosher
butcher because they're not Kosher yeah
it was literally a whole picture
baloney Pork and Sausage and it wasn't
turkey bacon it was literally like pork
yeah we zoomed in yeah you could see
Pork and Sausage so I'm like wait oh
this might be my Fairway order driver
then I'm like no I'm like are you at
Parky's he's like yeah I'm like what is
going on I'm going back and forth with
this guy he's like I'm at Park East I'm
like send me a picture of the store
because if he goes to the Butcher and
gets ground chicken I can't eat that
right so I'm like send me a picture of
the story he's literally sent me a
picture he's in parking Park East
I'm like what is going on I'm gonna send
you a picture of the chicken I said can
you send me a picture of the ground
chicken from the actual butcher station
he sends me a picture of the ground
chicken it has the sticker with Park
East on it like what in the world is
going on so I'm like okay I'll just I'm
like thinking I'm gonna wait and see
what shows up at my door right and I
call uh Park East and I'm like well
because what showed up at your door what
showed up at my door was oh this V
turkey that he said he couldn't find the
kosher brand and the ground chicken with
the label on it from Porky's correct
came in your order so I called Parky so
I'm like I know this is a crazy question
I've been shopping for literally 15
years at your store do you guys sell
bacon the lady pretty much like laughed
in my face she was like no is it kosher
butcher ma'am I'm like like no bacon
she's like we sell like turkey fake
bacon bacon I'm like no no like real
bacon she's like no I'm not sure Meyer
I'm like okay thank you so much I have
no idea
like the mystery remains a mystery I
have to imagine perhaps he went to the
wrong store at first and then I was like
wait are you at Park East he realizing
like ran across the street to Park East
I don't know it was a mystery Beyond
mystery he was like gaslighting me yeah
it was so crazy oh my God I was
chuckling so there's a small chance that
you're you're no the turkey no no it was
totally kosher like the packaging was
totally fine it's just where did that
picture come from where maybe it was
like a stock image he had like just from
previous chops perhaps and he wasn't
being like overly communicative he
thought it was annoying like
yeah
but he was he was like hey
yeah after that Saga he like just
messaged hey yeah after the whole thing
he's like hey I'm like what's up he's
like your card's been declined I'm like
what
that's not how it works because like my
you wouldn't be shopping with instacart
if my instacart order didn't go through
I used Apple pay and I called and it was
such drama it was such I called
instacart and I'm like did my card gets
cleaned they're like no Your Shopper
gonna be shopping if your card was clean
I'm like that's what I thought
I eventually just like I let go and let
God and the whole thing arrived
perfectly all worked out and it all
worked out and I had a good laugh and we
got a big vat of chili
what's better nothing nothing so that's
what I did yesterday
love that yeah
love that so we've got a great show we
do it's Tuesday you said there's an
abundance of stories yeah there were
like a lot of little stories that I
could have spoken about I had to trim
too love that yeah maybe they'll make it
into tomorrow's episode yeah that's what
I was thinking too
um they're not really pertinent but none
of the stories are like big news stories
but just like things in which to discuss
and interesting things full of
interesting factoids and some
interesting people but no one more
interesting than the camper and the
counselor no one which is my forthcoming
children's book that is available for
pre-order now anywhere you pre-order
books Amazon Indie bound Walmart Target
tertulia books a million I love books a
million million books books a million
Goodreads goals Goodreads I know
Goodreads was down yesterday I tried to
rate my book like what the internet and
then Spotify was giving us trouble
yesterday we believe our Spotify issue
is fixed I know and it was it was
specific to us yeah I know Spotify
um our episode from Friday and yesterday
like we're not uploading they're both
uploaded now and I believe we fixed the
issue but we'll see what happens today
but I think we're going sorry about that
yeah but I'm sorry like Goodreads
beating down that's not unacceptable
that's crazier than when like Instagram
goes down yeah I just don't think people
realize like
what a Cornerstone Goodreads is in our
lives I completely agree so it [__]
with me it was crazy
so you can also find the camber in the
counter on Goodreads where it does count
towards your Goodreads reading goal you
should add it to yourself I did read it
multiple times multiple multiple in the
time the amount of times that I've read
this I could have read a full book so it
counts it totally counts yeah so check
it out get your pre-orders in and thank
you not to be also like so self promo me
for both of us but also at five o'clock
today eastern time I'm doing another
Amazon live oh my gosh I know where I'll
be with the snitch we're doing like
summer Essentials how to get through
summer you know portable fans outfits
that don't chafe things like that it's
like the summer survival guide Amazon
live you can I'll post a link on my
story 5 p.m eastern time sorry Jax I
don't want to like step on yourself no
no I'm excited to watch I actually I
love doing it while I like suppress my
jealousy I know because you said that
you guys would be girly swirling and I I
identify as a girly swirly you identify
as a girly who does in fact swirling
right so it'll be tough it'll be tough
but I am going to enjoy I loved your
guys's last one and it's always good to
see what this Niche is up to it's always
good to see like what the hot items for
summer are that's so true I was very
influenced by higher last right Amazon I
got that Luke Combs t-shirt right so I
think I got a travel bag
great so I look forward to seeing what
you guys put forth tonight some good
stuff coming I want spoil it now without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that you do need to know and you
do need to know that the past five
stories that you do need to know are
brought to you by Caraway perfect segue
from our chili chili Caraway cookware is
non-toxic and chemical free so you can
fill your summer with your favorite
recipes without your without any worry
so Caraway is the best of the best when
it comes to cookware bakeware sets food
storage solutions I made my chili last
night in the Caraway I'm sure you'll be
reheating your chili in your Caraway it
will be because I have a Caraway set
here because I literally could not get
by without calorie like do I want toxins
in my food right thank you that's what's
great about Caraway non-toxic cookware
right and I also can't be like you know
standing over the sink like scrubbing
all this ceramic coated ceramic coated
nonstick it's the craziest thing like to
watch it all just slip off the pan and
especially when you're making a chili
and then you know you can get like that
crustacean at the bottom because it
cooks for a long time you're susceptible
to scrubbing not with Caraway you're
susceptible to crustacean and don't miss
caraway's summer refresh event from June
20th to July 15th for a limited time get
10 off site-wide on the internet's
favorite kitchenware it's the perfect
time to take care take care of all your
summer gifting it's ideal for both
graduates newlyweds and with cookware
bakeware food storage and tea kettles to
choose from there's something for
everyone their internet famous
kitchenware kitchenware is a staple for
any home it comes in a variety of modern
Shades to fit with any design aesthetic
so I mean they're they're having a big
sale right now it's going until July
15th you can get 10 off site-wide visit
carawayhome.com toast10 to get that 10
off during their summer refresh event
certain exclusions apply that's
carawayhome.com toast10 or use code
toast10 that's t-o-a-s-t-10 at checkout
Caraway non-toxic cookware made Modern
today's episode is also brought to you
by game time buying tickets to your
favorite events should not be stressful
but these days it is game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for the fun
you're actually going to have so game
time is the place for last minute ticket
deals if you don't like to plan months
in advance just like doesn't work for
your life that is so me game time has
deals on tickets right up to the day of
the event get exclusive Flash Deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater and more and the
game time guarantee means that you'll
always get the best price so if you find
tickets in the same same section and the
same Row for Less game time will credit
you a hundred and ten percent of the
difference game time is just a great app
to always have on your phone if you're
traveling you know you're out traveling
for work or taking a vacation and you
find yourself in a city with like
fabulous things going on just have game
time on your phone all the time you can
check up until the day of the event get
fabulous sporting events concerts comedy
shows which is more personal than
comedy
um it's the fastest growing ticket app
in the country for a reason you're
getting images of your seats before you
buy so you know exactly what to expect
you can buy tickets in a matter of
seconds and the tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem with code
toast for 20 off download the game time
app today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed
guaranteed thank you Claudia you're
welcome our first story Jennifer
Lawrence addresses rumors that Liam
Hemsworth cheated on Miley Cyrus with
her Jennifer Lawrence was on watch
Happens Live and made like a bunch of
waves you see her in Andy kiss no you
know Andy like has a thing where he like
kisses a bunch of people and she was the
one who was like should we do it and he
was like okay and the lips yeah Jackie I
don't think I've ever seen him so
nervous in his life he was like like
right now it was on the after show
um then she also told this crazy story
about
um what happened to her at the era's
tour because she knows she loves Bravo
and I had actually heard this story from
Craig Conover we went to the era store
together but this was a different era
store so in New York where did she go I
think Philly okay but in New York I went
to the era store with Paige and Craig um
and we like spent a lot of time together
in the car at home he told me the story
and he told me the story like from his
perspective and then she told the story
from her perspective and they were so
different
live and she was like so funny it was at
the era's tour and I was just like
living my best life yada yada and this
woman comes like because they're at this
tent in the middle of the floor like
anyone can go up celebrity the celebrity
tent this woman like comes with her
phone and like shoves it in Jennifer's
face she like beelines past security and
it's a FaceTime with Greg and Craig
excuse me and she's like Craig is just
like kind of sitting on the other phone
like on the other end of the line
expectantly being like yeah hey it's me
and when Craig told the story he was
like I had no idea like I don't think I
I I didn't even know where this person
was all of a sudden Jennifer Lawrence is
on the other end of the phone and he's
like hey so Craig's perspective and her
perspective were very different got it
so she was like being a little shady
that Craig was like Hey look at me yeah
like oh yeah it's me Jennifer Lawrence
like calling uh and Craig who was this
woman I don't remember he told me but I
don't remember like the connection and I
don't want to like misspeak I don't know
weird story yeah but I was like oh my
god I've heard this story but I heard it
so different like Craig was like I
literally was like out I had no idea why
this person was calling me next thing I
know Jennifer Lawrence is on the phone
oh that's so weird we need to identify
the woman and she needs to explain
herself yeah and her connection to
everyone
yeah well she obviously like knows Craig
from wherever and he's like why is she
calling me and he's waiting and this
woman thinks she's a hero because
Jennifer Lawrence loves Bravo and she
and she has Craig's phone number right
it's all on this woman yeah but this is
also another story from the general she
like she went on and she made a bunch of
news got it and she looked so beautiful
so beautiful she's literally looks
unreal I know she's oh she's literally
the most beautiful woman in the world
but it's like the looks The Styling the
hair the main hair the long hair the
long hair so she did um plead the fifth
on Watch What Happens Live last night
and
um say that she would love to respond to
the fleeing accusation that she had with
Liam Hemsworth she said and the the
rumor has been that like she and Liam on
the set of that movie where they wake up
on the thing Hunger Games oh sorry no I
was thinking of Chris Pratt my bad
um there's another rumor you mean the
biggest movie yeah on the side of The
Hunger Games while he was with Miley
right yeah they hooked up like at some
point while they were together and while
they were all you know filming right in
some of Miley's recent music like even
plays into that right so she said it not
true total rumor however she noted that
she and Chris which one I'm sorry I'm
like Luke
who Liam did KISS one time off screen it
was years after if the couple called it
quits though as for the rumors that
Miley shaded Jennifer in her flowers
music video in May by wearing a gold
dress reminiscent of Jennifer's Hunger
Games Premiere look Jennifer denied that
as well she said I just assumed that was
like a coincidence right it's not like
the most Niche specific it's like a gold
dress yeah and so she said she hopes
that fans are satisfied with her answer
I totally believe her I believe her too
like I don't think she needs to be out
here like being a harlot you know and
she doesn't give that energy no and I
think one she wouldn't bring it up if if
it were true and two like so much time
has passed and like Miley and Liam like
nobody still ships them anymore like if
it was ancient history because it would
have been like 10 years ago at this
point like she could say you know yeah
she could say she could I I wouldn't
hold it again certainly no and she gave
me like a little bit more overt in her
like her hints in her music and stuff
yeah but like they were young they're on
the biggest like movie their overnight
Sensations like it's easy to get caught
up yeah if they had little fling while
he was with Miley like I think 10 years
on like we could all move on from it I
feel like Jennifer Lawrence does a
really good job of like addressing
rumors about herself head on like for so
long there was like terrible rumors
about her and Harvey Weinstein and in
her Vogue 73 questions it's clear she
like wanted to clear it up what would
she say I think the question was like
what's the craziest thing you've ever
heard about yourself or something along
those lines and she's like that I slept
with Harvey Weinstein like so direct and
honestly I believed her the second she
said it like there's she has a really
good way of like addressing things she
doesn't do it in the moment but she
always does it and I like that well
she's also not really accessible so
she's there's no
even
um
way that we expect her to address things
in the moment she's not on Instagram
like she's not like responding to
everything which puts her in a really
nice place yeah then we're not like
sitting around waiting what does Jayla
have to say she gives us nothing right
and then when she does things like this
like it feels like she gives us
everything right and it feels like she's
like so honest and she's been wanting to
say it for a while yeah I believe this
yeah I believe this too
because it's like harmless yeah
and it's so long yeah yeah are you ready
for our next story yeah in a theme of
people being unwell and needing to learn
how to behave
when were we talking about that just
it's just a common theme okay and you'll
know what I know the story too Pink the
artist was stunned by a fan throwing her
mother's ashes onto stage during show
pink was left gobsmacked after a concert
goer tossed a bag of their mother's
ashes on stage during her headlining set
at the British summertime Festival in
London over the weekend
she picked up the plastic bag holding
the cremated remains and said is this
your mom with a shocked expression on
her face pink then admitted I don't know
how I feel about this before staggering
to her feet and placing the ashes on the
edge of the stage the pop star could
also be seen shaking her hands as if
trying to clean them behind a speaker
before continuing to sing her song Just
Like a Pill while still looking
astounded just as fast as I can to them
in love nowhere
and I swear I need to say pig live yeah
um but not a [__] like this is going to
be going down people are deeply unwell
people need to stop throwing things on
stage people need to leave artists alone
and just like go to a concert and enjoy
it and like a human being and I'm sure
there's like a Sentimental reason behind
this like I'm sure maybe they heard this
girl's mom loved pink yeah whatever and
if you want to like honestly like take
your the Ashes to the concert with you
yeah no and like sprinkle them on the
grass I agree like it's weird but you
know what do it in your own private
thing it to throw anything to an artist
on stage no matter what it is even like
a flower like in this day and age just
don't like it's so weird and this I mean
to be confronted with a bag of Ashes of
someone you don't know I have I'd say
has happened to me
um at summer camp
someone I know you know brought some of
you know their parents ashes with them
and I had went into her like her cubby
for a second to get something and I was
like oh LOL what's this I'd never seen
ashes before you were snooping no no I
believe I was asked to go into the cubby
like I was invited into the cubby I
wasn't snooping okay because it kind of
feels like you were in someone's private
space no no I think she was like go into
my company and get that for me or
something something like that and I was
I swear to God I wasn't snooping and
there was like a bag of dirt and I had
never seen ashes before I was really
young and we don't do that in our faith
we we don't cremate so I literally
picked it up I'm like why do you have a
bag of dirt and she was like oh that's
my dad
and I actually I think I remembered
crying like I was very
um
shook by it it was just like crazy and
so I feel for pain not to make
everything about me no literally
literally I'm just kind of I'm harking
back to an experience that feels
relevant here I don't think that's me
making it by myself no I feel like you
can hardpack to the experience like once
we talked about how this could affect
pink you know yeah I guess I didn't like
give her the space to heal you didn't
give her space no I didn't and create
space for her either which was really
disgusting of me
no you've never created space no not for
a single other human being in my life
but thank you for sharing you know my
trauma you already traveled how this
might have impacted you and and how I'm
now like feeling triggered
but like this girl like she like yeah
she heard pink but she also hurt me too
because now I'm reliving that right and
that's really hard for me that is really
hard but it does remind me of the Bebe
rexha story from last week like just
people not saying the difference right
that was that infuriated me I hope she
presses charges yeah I mean he was
arrested oh and I saw on Tick Tock last
night I don't know if it's like verified
or not but like he's like acting out on
social media now like no you don't know
how to catch and no no hate this person
and I hope she took his her phone and
threw it into the water because they
were at the pier yeah right she could
have just tossed it right over I hope
she took her big heel and she stomped on
it yeah
um this is so weird like people and I
think it's more reflective of the state
of our culture yeah everyone just like
want no I'm not I don't know this person
I don't know what their intentions were
but like
it feels like you want attention yeah
like this is a moment like or you're so
deeply unwell that like
some part of you like thinks that giving
pink your mom's house is a normal thing
to do right and like pink would
appreciate it and that that's like
acceptable behavior it's so weird
and I kind of like that pink didn't play
it off it's like oh I'm sorry for your
like like you should feel weird you
should be shamed I'm sorry I know you're
probably grieving but like just to set
the precedent because now this video has
gone viral and I think people see like
artists like accept things from fans on
on videos online and be like oh I can do
that too and like encourages that type
of behavior so for her to kind of Shame
her and be like well this is weird I
think it might deter other people from
doing something similar yeah hopefully
but maybe not because some like
attention is attention right
it's so weird and I'm sure the girls
like dying because like now it's major
news and imagine having like ash on your
hands and you're just trying to like
sing and twirl in the air it's just I'm
sure actually like the ashes did create
like a nice grip you know she's always
grabbing onto poles and like doing flips
and tricks and maybe it created a nice
little friction for her you know like
like when you do that at gym like yeah
you put chalk on your hands before you
lift so maybe it was like kind of a
it was thoughtful it was a helping hand
I'm just trying to put a positive spin
on a weird situation
yeah
but I like where your head's at yeah
overall [__] weird and don't do this
like just don't
I don't feel like I have to say that
because I feel like The Toasters are
like normal people it's not the toasters
who are doing this no
but I mean throughout
pop culture history like fans have
thrown things onto stages like bras yep
that's always been accepted flowers as
you said yeah I just feel like in this
day and age like
everyone's on such high alert because
such weird crazy things happen that like
if somebody comes flying at you you
don't know it's a flower like you you
spook uh of course and Kelly Clarkson
was talking about that on the Howard
Stern interview she did just like
something totally innocuous like
happens like somebody even when not to
make everything around myself but like
even when I'm doing like a show and like
somebody gets up to go to the bathroom
and the footsteps because of Acoustics
on stage sometimes it can sound like the
footsteps are coming from behind you and
it's so [__] scary like even like
just sit down and shut up
everywhere no matter where you go don't
go to the bathroom
oh okay no I'm kidding but like even
something uh what's the word innocuous
yeah like innocent like a flower like it
can spook someone because every we're
all on such high alert yeah because
everyone's crazy everyone's crazy
Disturbed yeah so I think everyone
should get help yeah you know I think so
yeah we can go back to enjoying life's
Simple Pleasures where you could throw a
flower on a stage and a broad Harry
Styles yeah people are always throwing
things at him yeah really bad like water
bottles
and he he reprimands people like he's
like stop no the like
like and it also it depends like pink I
feel like doesn't have like crazy fans
so I feel like yes this is something
that would happen at like a Harry
concert or even like a Taylor Swift
concert like really impassioned cult
like pink is just like a famous artist
with tons of fans she doesn't have like
a cult after her but it happens to even
the best of them it does but you're
underestimating the power of pain so
true we're strong what do you guys call
yourselves I don't know I'm not a part
of them okay I listen I enjoy passively
yeah like a normal person should yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
it's a little fashion news want to get
your take on it why because I'm so
fashionable yeah look at your outfit
fancy pants
uh the giacomas runway show was in Paris
yesterday and star started it was
star-studded it was at Versailles
the clothing was a question mark and I
want to know your thoughts because fans
are roasting Kendall Jenner's Jack Miss
runway show look saying it's giving
diaper okay I actually liked her look
yeah so this book has been very like not
controversial because it's just it went
viral but it went viral for being like
do we like it like is this fashion is
this a joke what is this and it's really
hard for me to have an opinion because
it's on Kendall right and everything on
Kendall I like so I thought it looked
great on Kendall if I was wearing it I
think I would feel differently like if
you went out to dinner in this I would
feel differently I think you'd be
arrested but also giacomas like I feel
like when they popped on the scene they
were like doing crazy like they invented
like that tiny purse that everybody wore
maybe they didn't invented excuse me but
theirs was the one that like blew up and
everyone's like what are you keeping
that tiny person they're always doing
like shock and awe yeah yeah so I don't
think it's that I didn't see anything
that was that crazy I thought Gigi
hadid's outfit was beautiful I didn't
think it was that crazy I don't know why
everyone's like getting their panties in
a Twist yeah I didn't think it was that
crazy I looked at some of the other
looks from the show because I just
wanted to see what they were doing and
it wasn't anything like
groundbreaking right or or like that
shocking no there was a nipple though
there's always a nipple it's so fashion
but what was cool was the show itself
and I I didn't feel like the clothes
were worthy of a show at Versailles
that's a fair criticism yeah because
their size like opulent right they could
have just like walked down around my
head a studio today yeah yeah no that's
fair or a park but the guests of the
show were on little boats in the lake I
wouldn't see that and then the girls
were like on the runway yeah that's cool
right that's different yeah I like that
I like that too so what do you think
about the look
well I think you said it best
um
Kendall Jenner could quite literally
wear a diaper and it would look good so
she they're saying she looks like she's
wearing a diaper and it does look good I
think I think maybe it's a commentary
let's offer this on motherhood no I
think it's a commentary on a thesis
we've been speaking about here for a
really long time like Kendall Jenner
could wear a diaper and look good and
she did she wore a diaper and she looked
good yeah
so it's really like it's not even about
the clothes
well that's true I believe that like I
think fashion is so subjective it's just
about the person wearing it like do they
feel good do they look good yes ugly's
ugly but yeah but then also like clothes
can make a person yes that's true like
anything else it's a balance it's a
balance I didn't think it was that crazy
like me neither and you know what the
more I look at it it's also on Kindle so
I do like it her legs are so low I like
what I'm looking at yeah you know
um but I also like it like I don't think
people will actually I don't want to see
someone like going out to dinner in this
really no but I feel like there's a way
to make it a little more
Street friendly yeah I could see like
like a young Starlet like there was that
period where Ariana Grande wore like a
lot of stuff in the silhouette I could
see like Olivia Rodrigo like and I was
like so crazy with a pair of tights yeah
cool tights big chunky shoes yeah so
like we're closed we're close yeah it
doesn't it doesn't feel so crazy to me
and I thought it was it was a fabulous
outing and I loved all the photos we had
so much footage of all the famous models
and girlies and I loved it yeah it was
cute it was just like a great High
fashion moment it was is it Fashion Week
or something I don't think you were so
asking the wrong girl I feel like it's
always fashion like no I feel like
always having a show in the middle of
not fashion I know because I feel like
it's always fashion month we know it's
like New York Paris Milan like it's in
the same month then there's all these
like Rogue shows and then we have you
know and then we have resort resort and
then we have of course like the very
highly acclaimed OC Fashion Week and it
was just like a lot there's a lot
there's fall Spring Resort OC winter
spring summer joggers right there's
always that
it's hard to keep trackers
are you ready for our next story is it
the next story that's brought to you by
the perfect bar because if it isn't I
don't want to hear it
well thank God it is this episode is
brought to you by the perfect bar the
original refrigerated protein bar that
you know we love if you haven't heard
perfect bar just launched a new line of
protein bars called perfect bar layers
perfect bar layers are a new line of
crispy protein bars stacked with three
delicious layers and packed with whole
food nutrition they're made with a
crispy base of peanut and cashew butter
layered with dark chocolate or 100 real
fruit and then they're sprinkled with
toasted gluten-free oats they're packed
with up to 11 grams of protein and they
come in two delicious flavors crispy
peanut butter and chocolate and crispy
peanut butter and Berry it's basically a
healthy peanut butter and jelly and
because they're made with only whole
food ingredients which is their classic
blend of 20 organic superfoods and they
contain no artificial preservatives
perfect bar layers are stored in the
fridge you could say that these bars are
stacked and packed if you aren't
convinced already there are also non-GMO
project verified gluten-free soy-free
kosher and low GI the best part is that
you can now find them in the
refrigerated section at Target
Nationwide these bars are not only
delicious but they're just great to
always have on hand at your house we
keep some in the studio I keep a bunch
of my fridge at home and just like throw
them in your bag if you're gonna have a
long day ahead of you they're really
good they keep you full they've got tons
of protein and perfect bar knows that
it'll be Love At First Bite so they're
offering you a chance to try their new
refrigerator refrigerated protein bars
for free here's how it works sign up for
email or text and upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they'll reimburse you for the
cost of one bar directly into your
venmower PayPal account all you have to
do is go to perfect snacks.com toast to
get a free Perfect part today that's
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today happy snacking today's
episode is also brought to you by Athena
Club
probably my favorite razor of all time
and my only critique of Athena Club is
that it's too good that Ben keeps using
it and it's so annoying so the blade on
our old razors used to get really goopy
after a few uses but we love the water
activated serum on Athena clubs razors
there's just enough of it to soothe
while shaving but it never gets that
like gunky chunky like mucus type thing
you said it Sis it's time to get
friendly with our razors again and
honestly there's no better razor out
there than the Athena Club razor shaving
used to be something we dreaded but
Athena Club products have seriously made
it more fun and easy to shave
um also their holder their magnetic
holder is by far the best one I've used
I've used a bunch of bracers that say
like oh we have this thing it's on the
floor it's on the floor my Athena Club
one has been up for probably two months
and has not Fallen it's fabulous
after the first few shaves with our old
razor it just never shaved as well and
Since switching to Athena Club I've
sincerely gotten zero razor bumps with
their razor so it's designed with
built-in skin guards to help prevent
razor burn while being gentle on curves
plus the razor blade is surrounded by
water activated serums like [__] with
shea butter and hyaluronic acid which we
all know is Holy Grail for skin care the
best part is that the razor kit is only
ten dollars and it comes with two blade
heads a magnetic hook for shower storage
and your choice of handle color the
handle options are super cute but they
also black and white razors if you're a
minimalist and with Athena Club you
never have to think about blade refills
because you choose how often you want
the replacement blades shipped to you
and you can also Now find them in Target
stores nationwide so it's easy to swing
by one of the many Target stores
whenever you need more blades switch to
the better razor and show your skin you
care with Athena Club get started today
by shopping in store at Target stores
nationwide just head to the Shaving
aisle and find the Razor kit the cloud
shave foam the wax strips and the razor
refills again Target you can shop Athena
club now which is fabulous thanks you're
welcome our next story Louis Capaldi is
taking a break from touring and for
foreseeable future
for touring in the foreseeable future
for mental and physical health so Lewis
Capaldi has revealed that he's taking a
break from touring for now for the sake
of his health he announced the news in a
statement shared on his Instagram
Tuesday and called it the most difficult
decision of his life his announcement
comes after he struggled to finish his
set at Glastonbury on Saturday and was
supported by the crowd ahead of his set
at the English music festival he had
canceled three weeks of performances in
order to rest and recover both mentally
and physically he said the fact that
this probably won't come as a surprise
doesn't make it any easier to write but
I'm very sorry to let you know I'm going
to be taking a break from touring for
the foreseeable future I used to be able
to enjoy every second of shows like this
and I'd hoped three weeks away would
sort me out but the truth is I'm still
learning to adjust to the impact of my
Tourette's and on Saturday it became
obvious that I need to spend much more
time getting my mental and physical
health in order so I can keep doing
everything I love for a long time to
come yeah I think that video went really
viral where he was trying to you know
perform at Glastonbury and the fans were
like cheering and screaming and singing
and losing really heartwarming but it
was clear like this is a person in need
of like a major break yeah and I've been
seeing videos like that for the last few
months he does suffer from Tourette's so
he can't like finish his songs and the
fans always like come through for him
but I'm sure one it's really hard from
him and that's not like the kind of show
that he wants to be doing and I'm sure
it's really emotional so I'm glad that
he's taking time off from touring but I
also feel like an art like there should
be an artist who's just like I'm gonna
be a musician I'm gonna make art I'm
gonna put out songs that I love because
he's so talented and like yeah one of my
favorite artists and be like and I'm not
touring at all I know the thing is
when you are an artist like the actual
all the money is in touring like most
artists are not in like great record
deals they don't make a ton of money
from like streaming what everyone knows
it's like you know 10 cents for a
million streams so the real money is
touring merch all that for sure but like
you can earn a very good like he's a top
artist yes just his money alone and even
licensing his songs for movies and
commercials like he could earn a very
good living and not have to struggle so
deeply like mentally and emotionally and
he at a certain point like he can't do
it so I would as a fan of his like a
huge fan of his if he was just like I'm
gonna make music and you're not gonna
see me out and about
um and I hope that's okay
yeah did Sia ever like go on tour
membership that major album Elastic
Heart chandelier like it was the biggest
album of all time and I feel like she
doesn't tour
let's Google it I'm sure that she did
did but it's also I feel like it's a
part of your record label deal like you
have to put out a certain amount of
Tours and shows yeah they lock you in
you can get tickets for 2023. but no I
hear what you're saying and I do think
there are other artists who put out like
you know decent music not that
frequently and are just constantly on
tour right it is very Revenue generating
and it might be like fun for them to
travel and yes take their friends and it
depends what stage of your life you're
at but like I am totally fine with an
artist who who can't tour and but I'm
sure he wants to meet his fans and sings
the song live and hear it sung back to
him right and that must be really hard
but
he needs to take time for himself yeah
no it's interesting I feel like we do
live in an age where like you could
become like an enormous star Without
Really touring
um but I feel like that's half the fun
you know that's why people get into this
business yes but also like touring is
also where things go wrong so many times
well I I was that's reminds me I feel
like someone who's dude I feel like is
doing that like we'll be doing that in
the future it's Justin Bieber yeah I was
saying the same thing like every time he
does a tour it's not okay because
there's like mental health issues
physical health issues he's just like
not happy oh you know who doesn't tour
but she also like doesn't really release
music that frequently Selena Gomez
yes but I mean she did have an album but
she did she didn't do a tour for her
album her most recent one
yeah I feel like she's someone who fully
prioritizes her mental health and she
makes so much money from her other
Ventures that she doesn't need to tour
yeah Selena Gomez yeah
every time like an artist goes on tour I
feel like even like obviously this is
fictional but like Daisy Jones and the
six yeah like that tour broke them yeah
I feel like whenever Ari goes on tour
she makes a documentary about how
miserable it is yeah yeah
that's so true I'm just saying I feel
like Taylor Swift's having like the time
of her life on this tour yes but she's
not an ordinary tour it's not an
ordinary tour it's like totally on her
terms and it's kind of like I mean until
it went Global but let's see how the the
global peace goes for her the Global
Peace will go what do you mean in terms
of sales no no oh no in terms of just
like mental health yeah mental health
having time for yourself yeah I feel
like by now she's like figured out what
works for her and doing like these
weekend show like huge shows
five days off yeah is going well for her
um but it's a lot yeah it's a lot of
time away from home yeah it is but
you're right it does depend on like what
stage in life you're in I think like
when you're in your early 20s like
traveling a lot and being away from home
is like exciting and when you're on the
up like every show you do you're getting
more fans it's like you know it's like
in a movie where you're just like
climbing the charts but when you're
there already then you're looking for
you're not looking for that exactly
you're looking for something else yeah
well I wish him the best I wish him the
best I love him as a p John as a fan I
completely support this decision yeah
now our fifth and final story is some
tech news that I heck that I find really
interesting a new smartphone app made by
ex Google engineer will calculate the
calories in any meal by scanning a
picture of the meal so talk like I
nobody you're living for it no no it's
not no but a lot of people track their
food and it's really inaccurate like so
inaccurate should you make something
from home and like rest no at home is
easier you know exactly yeah at a
restaurant like how much butter did they
know but like how does this camera know
okay so anyone who's eaten out in the
past years has felt and maybe came to
the urge to snap a pic of a particularly
well-plated or photogenic entree for
social media but now there might finally
be a practical and legitimately
constructive reason to photograph all
those perfectly seared veggies Burgers
Etc former engineers at Google and
defense contractor Raytheon have created
a cell phone app that can count the
calories in any meal by simply taking a
photo like it's how it's called Snap
calorie it's already available for
download on Apple's apps store in Google
Play for free with a 30 month 30 per
month premium option it's better 30
dollars a month it's better at
eyeballing the calorie content why if
you were to do like a a program a
program yeah no but it's just like a lot
how much you pay for face tune
excuse me wow
um I pay like 25 a year oh okay okay for
like the premium one worth every penny
student two yeah greater than facing two
actually phase two and one like really
gets the job done I totally agree but
phase one two had now some perks I can't
live without yeah yeah yeah like
changing the background yeah I have so
much fun it's better at eyeballing the
calorie count content of addition and
professional nutritionists
um so this is how it looks so you could
see like they they like x-ray the plate
well yeah well they're x-raying like a
banana and an apple which anyone can
tell you like my bowl of chili your bowl
of chili so I think like those like
Darkness like it was probably like fat
like yeah yeah I don't know I guess it
kind of makes sense so the photo online
is like an x-ray image of like an apple
and a banana standing on a plate and
like the apple and banana have like
different colors I guess the different
colors represent different things yeah
and it's
there's like if it does what it says it
does which I still don't understand the
science behind like you know how to take
a picture and like know how much oil was
in this yeah how much sugar whatever but
that could be game changing because I
really do feel like whenever I'm trying
to be conscious of like calorie
consumption it's like how do you know no
and like many years ago I did Weight
Watchers and I loved it and I would like
track my food and like I would know that
like the stuff I was putting in because
like I was kind of lying to was like not
fully like 100 you know yeah and so with
a lot of
food tracking apps like you can always
scan the barcode of what you're eating
but if it's like something that's
homemade or at a restaurant it's really
hard to gauge it it could you could be
off by hundreds of calories yes that's
so interesting so I think this is a good
use of yeah personally I will be
downloading because 30 a month is a lot
and honestly like
I just prefer not to know you know
uh well some people want yeah you know
but this is they use AI to do this
that's what I figured um I I ai's just
like a blanket statement but we were
also talking about yesterday
um this AI children's toy that's
forthcoming oh I don't remember in the
we were talking about in the chat this
um Bear yeah oh this AI bear in the next
few years your kid could talk to it and
then like talk back and like learn about
your kid and like tell the kid to like
it like listens to what your kid is
saying and then becomes like the friend
and talks back to it and like you know
gives advice yeah like which is just so
scary it's giving Ashley a Black Mirror
yeah it's also giving Clara in the sun I
didn't read it
I won't make you thanks but I will not
be getting that no not for Harry because
Harry is empty it gives the best advice
right you want to go tell a story go
tell your auntie you want to go hear a
story go listen to your auntie you want
to go seek advice from a great maternal
figure
who's not your mother sometimes you need
to talk to like you know an aunt okay
like the cool app you better [__]
tell me what he said yeah of course no
and like me and Harry like I'll sneak
him cigarettes when he's like 16 you
know no I don't know that's kind of bad
team I'm going to be I don't know about
that yeah me and her getting lit on the
weekends yeah no Harry will be like my
designated driver
fine that that's fine good auntie nephew
bonding time yeah love that for us uh so
those are the fast five stories you
definitely need to know them I'll be
checking out that app one day not today
don't need to know today so tomorrow I
am in Studio with girl boss Town Robin
is returning to the toast Thursday Jax
is back in studio and I just think
that's great I think that is great I
look forward thank you so much for
getting here I know it's hard
yeah getting here is hard being here is
fine except it's a million degrees in
here it's like a thousand degrees in
here I'm heading for a Sula yeah which
is crazy you're having a sweaty upper
lip here use my fan oh thank you I want
to use my fan when we podcast but I
think it like picks up in the microphone
so I'll wrap this up thank you very much
so much for listening to the testimony
Morning Show where we deliver the
fastest stories you need to know
everybody on YouTube for watching us on
YouTube please subscribe give this video
a thumbs up
Spotify
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day love you bye